gargoyles those stony goblin-like
creatures that glare down at you from
their perches among the spires of
universities and cathedrals
why are they there what is their
function how did they find their way
onto our buildings let alone into our
living rooms
somehow these mainstays of gothic
architecture climbed into our
imaginations
and developed their own story lines
sometimes they attack us
sometimes they defend us sometimes they
terrify us and sometimes they make us
laugh
sometimes they are supernatural and
sometimes they are just
really good at camouflage quite an
accomplishment considering that
historically they're just
water spouts i'm dr emily zarka
and this is monstrum the gargoyle might
very well be the world's
only monster inspired by architecture
the ancient egyptians greeks and
etruscans used waterspouts designed to
look
like an animal head most often a lion
whose purpose was to prevent
rain water from eroding the surfaces of
tombs and other structures
by diverting it through a hole that was
almost always in the shape of an open
mouth
but why do we call these features
gargoyles today the prevailing myth
harkens back to another monster
a notorious water dragon gargoule
allegedly terrorized france by
swallowing ships in the sun
and spitting torrents of water out of
its mouth flooding the surrounding land
and causing destruction
the 1400 year old story goes a priest
vowed to kill the beast if the town's
people built a church
they did and the priest defeated the
creature one of the acts he was later
canonized for
but the dragon's head and neck
mysteriously failed to decay along with
the rest of the body
and according to the legend the dragon's
head was mounted on the town
wall that's how the gargoyle earned its
name
the word gargoyle is derived from the
french dragon gargoule
which itself comes from the latin word
gargula meaning
gullet or throat the gothic style of
gargoyle is believed to date back as far
as the 12th century
the gargoyles still adorning the leon
cathedral in france
thanks to some very careful restoration
date back to 1220 ce
of course france's most famous gargoyles
watch over paris from their perches atop
notre dame
by the end of the 13th century the
gothic gargoyle was a trendy if
practical accessory there is an
incredible variety of gargoyles from
this period
although some look similar no two are
identical
but they have a few things in common
they are exaggerated or grotesque
they are fanciful and can be frightening
or ugly in appearance
in fact the word grotesque is so
commonly associated with these creatures
that they are often just called
architectural grotesques
though it's important to note that while
a gargoyle can be a grotesque
not all grotesques are gargoyles since
some aren't designed to divert rainwater
associated with the fancifully absurd
these carvings and sculptures are
characterized by their distorted
features and unusual hybrid
representations
often combining humans real animals and
fantastic beasts
why did these strange stone carvings
become popular beyond their practical
purpose
and why so monstrous well no one is
quite sure
although we have some theories one
theory goes since few people in the
medieval period could read
it is possible that the physical
existence of the frightening gargoyle
was meant to illustrate the prevailing
idea that evil could be made manifest
that ugliness and sin were real forces
in their lives
another is that the gargoyles were meant
as guardians so terrifying and hideous
that they would scare away evil and
designate the outside and the inside
out there lies temptation and evil but
within these walls you are safe
they do show up on a lot of churches
or perhaps they were just meant to
entertain much the way 20th century
gargoyles do
while the word gargoyle appeared in
literature before the 1900s
it was in the context of the water spout
not an actual fictional being
but in 1908 we are introduced to one of
the earliest versions of a living
gargoyle
dorothy and the wizard in oz the fourth
book in the popular oz series by l frank
balham
features soundless winged flying wooden
creatures with
ugly faces who are scared of loud noises
and they are distinctly called gargoyles
in the text
as wooden people i'm not sure if they
really qualify as the first gargoyle
monster but
i suppose it's up for debate first
published in the pulp magazine weird
tales in 1932
the maker of gargoyles by clark ashton
smith is widely considered the actual
first
incidence of architectural gargoyles
brought to life
by evil set in 12th century france the
story follows town outcast
in stonemason blaze renard as he carves
two gargoyles for the local cathedral
reynard treated horribly by the town's
people unwittedly transfers his rage
into one of the gargoyles
and his lust and desire into the other
one gargoyle is a murderous cat-headed
monster with claws and bird-like wings
and the other a horned seder with talons
and wings like a bat
one night a flying monster as black as
suit sees as a man on the street with
its towns
and tears at his throat his companion
narrowly escapes the same fate
simultaneously another winged creature
is terrorizing the women
molesting them with its gaze while
technically preserving their chastity
as the attacks continue a drunken
reynard aggressively pursues nicolette
the server at a tavern and the object of
his affections
when suddenly the window panes shatter
and both flying terrors enter
it is instantly apparent to all inside
that the monsters are the gargoyles that
adorn the cathedral
come to life reynard is knocked
unconscious by one of their heavy wings
the next morning raynar takes a hammer
from his workshop
and confronts the stony gargoyles on the
cathedral roof
he finds the cat-headed one stained with
blood and ripped
pieces of nicolette's dress on the
talons of the winged seder
he tries to destroy the incarnations but
they animate and
fight back lifting him off of the
church's eaves and high into the air
he manages to take off one of their
clawed legs but doing so causes them to
drop him
sending him plummeting to his death
below
reynard's broken body is found in the
square by the archbishop
the stone claw still embedded in his
shoulder
the horn of vapula by louis spence also
published in 1932
tells the story of a bishop who's packed
with satan binds his demon familiar into
a horned and godish gargoyle
giving it the ability to move and
terrorize the countryside for some 200
years
after these first two stories a few
other gargoyle monsters showed up here
and there in literature
but it wasn't really until the 1970s
that they became more popularly
recognized
thanks to television the silver screen
and a very popular role-playing game
in 1971 a stone gargoyle named bach came
to life because of the evil magic in the
ever popular doctor who
a fairly formidable foe he could
vaporize objects and was relatively
indestructible
i've got a machine outside that can
narrate you until the doctor destroyed
the master
who controlled him and bach along with
him the following year the made-for-tv
movie
gargoyles presented a world in which
gargoyles live in caves in new mexico
watching over thousands of gargoyle eggs
it's not a
good movie but it's also kind of awesome
after all the emmy award-winning special
effects makeup combined with the
creative use of slow motion
cinematography
bring the gargoyles to life with unique
movement and characteristics
you can't quite take them seriously but
they are interesting to look at
then in 1974 the original edition of the
fantasy role-playing game
dungeons and dragons the white box set
was released
and it included gargoyles as a chaotic
evil creatures
who can freeze as still as stone
dungeons and dragons helped and still
helps
popularize gargoyles as living breathing
monsters
cult classic ghostbusters brought
gargoyles back to their grotesque animal
roots
in 1984 with the keymaster and the
gatekeeper
represented by demonic hellhounds or
terror dogs
who reach the human world by manifesting
into stone gargoyles
then in the 1990s the animated series
gargoyles changed the trajectory of the
monster
expanding on their potential
architectural symbolism as
protectors by making them physical
defenders of humanity
the gargoyles are depicted as
superheroes instead of monsters
this idea of gargoyles as friendly
monsters was reinforced in 1996
when disney's the hunchback of notre
dame introduced anthropomorphic
gargoyles
victor hugo and laverne quasimodo's
guardians and best friends
who pretend to be lifeless during the
day
the gargoyle as a living monster is a
modern fiction but that doesn't mean we
aren't still
creating the architectural
embellishments this gargoyle photo from
scotland's
paisley abbey went viral in 2013
after people compared it to the famous
monster from the alien film franchise
the abbey's minister believes the
stonemasons who refurbished the abbey in
the early 1990s
including the replacement of 12 of the
original gargoyles
were probably having a bit of fun to
whoever is responsible for this epic
continuation of gargoyle history
i salute you there's no singular
symbolic meaning for gargoyles and it's
unlikely there ever was after all
crouching in the eaves of buildings they
are hard to see
and probably not meant to be recognized
by the casual observer
we see their detail mostly through the
lenses of binoculars and camera zooms
they are a flourish an adornment that
took on a life of its own
i would argue that that's one of the
reasons why our imaginations transform
them into living creatures
glimpsed only in the shadows guarding or
threatening
open to interpretation gargoyles are
all about speculation the idea that
something
looks inanimate could actually be
watching you is scary
whether that's a frightening face
peering at you from the top of a
building
or some terrible predator with the
ability to stand stone still
to hunt you more successfully still i'm
a fan of the funnier depictions of
gargoyles in both real life and fiction
like that alien inspired gargoyle or
this darth vader one
these are not meant to scare us but to
amuse us like architectural easter eggs
waiting to be discovered and marveled at
honoring that tradition is actually
paying homage to the past
we don't know for sure why gargoyles
were so popular in the medieval period
that they became a defining feature of
gothic architecture
but i like to think it all comes down to
something so fundamental and simple
even today humans seek entertainment
we all love a good grotesque okay
low yeah it's alone the gargoyle's still
adorned
by carl ash clark widgets oh wait mess
that up